the whole internet thinks nate did it
wheeler's talking to everyone close to
us and the media is turning this into
some true crime must-see tv crap
so we have to make sure we're on the
same page let me guess
that means your page you are the brains
of the operation after all just tell us
what you think we should do i mean
i'm just the blonde one i need help
okay we don't talk to reporters we give
them something else to talk about
like what like a new suspect i mean we
know the cops think we work together so
they're not going to listen to any of
the theories unless we have hard
evidence but the media those vultures
will turn the slightest hint of
something into some national news story
so if we set them on the right trail
maybe the cops will follow okay but how
are we supposed to do that someone's
posting about that claiming to be the
killer
so we start there i still think it's
janae i mean who else would know simon's
passwords and you said they were
fighting about the app yeah they were
fighting but not enough for her to kill
him over it yeah i don't think it was
just about the app
she was mad at him about something else
something personal like what
were they together
i mean she was definitely into him right
that's perfect we know the media loves a
love or spat so if we lay low so they
don't have anything new to say about us
we give them something on janae maybe
they'll run with it and they won't go
through our trash
i actually agree
i'm trying to be on espn not tmz
i could talk to her
i not to brag
but i'm like really good at getting
gospel out of people that's good but
you'd have to record it
we need something to leak to the press
i won't [ __ ] it up
i promise
[Music]
where were you
nowhere
question when you lie to me do you
actually expect me to believe it or do
you just hope that i won't call you out
on it i'm not lying
i went on a drive okay
if you can't trust me then i guess i
shouldn't trust you either what's that
supposed to mean
means that i finally got into some of
simon's encrypted files and i found
something but i'm not gonna show you
until you tell me where you were
fine
i was with nate
and addie and cooper
are you insane so you guys really do
have some kind of murder club it's what
everyone's calling it on instagram that
doesn't mean you should call it that if
anything it's a mutual acceleration club
because none of us did it you don't know
that
i think one of them might have
i found it in a backup of his dress
simon wrote that the same day that he
wrote the post about you and addie and
nate
this can't be real it is
whoever's posting on about that changed
cooper's secret and my guess is that
that someone is cooper
okay hold on
slow down what did the original post say
it doesn't matter the point is that
whoever changed cooper's post did it
after simon was dead who would do that
other than cooper well
depends what the secret is
are you gonna tell me
okay
but you have to promise you won't say
anything to anyone
i promise
the real post says that um
he's gay
oh
wow huh
that's um
unexpected mae thinks we should just
drop the laptop off of the police
station anonymously but then if cooper
isn't the one that changed the post and
i outed him for no reason then it's just
unforgivable but if he did change it the
police need to know right which is why i
couldn't sleep and it sucks because we
can't do anything until tomorrow and if
i could sleep maybe i could see things a
little bit more clearly but then my
brain it's just playing ping-pong with
itself i actually have a trick for that
i don't want drugs huh
no when i can't stop thinking about
something i don't want to think about i
watch horror movies
and that makes you feel better totally i
mean when you're bracing for the next
jump scare you don't have time to think
about anything else
that actually makes sense
so
have you seen the birds
no
what
okay we need to fix that right now are
you gonna watch with me
yeah i mean you kind of got my head
spinning too rojas
i'm gonna send you the link
you ready
okay
three
two
one
[Music]
you